we welcome in the head coach of the
Indianapolis Colts Frank rank joins us
on the program
coach good to have you on we got to do
something with the background there
behind you if you like you like what's
going on you got nothing behind you you
know you had to call me out on that
right away you got nothing you look like
you're in a hotel room or something I'm
worried about you FairPoint and you know
what then I actually even had some guys
help me out and say hey give me all the
do's and don'ts of Zoom protocol and one
of them is don't have a plain white
background well mission accomplished you
did you did well you didn't listen to
them if if we had a throwing contest of
head coaches right now how do you think
you'd fare I think I fare pretty well
I'm you know Doug Peterson would
certainly be up there we throw it around
a little bit when I was in Philadelphia
there's a few guys out there but I still
like getting a ball in my hand and
throwing around I don't do it that much
out of practice but I like to stay in
shape and I like to have a football in
my hands Kliff Kingsbury might be my
pick there well I'd be a good pick you
know he's got a he's a few years younger
but if it came down to accuracy that's
where if you're just talking distance
man one thing but we got to talk about
accuracy I think I got a chance knackers
I see hard ball throwing around all the
time like he he it feels like he's ready
to play no doubt and I think he's
inspired us all to let us know it's okay
to do that you can still you can still
want to throw the ball around and it's
not like you're trying to reach back to
your former career you just you like
being around it we like I like throwing
a ball I mentioned this yesterday I
didn't realize I thought you still had
the greatest comeback in college
football history I think you got knocked
down to number three on that list but
the NFL come back with the bills is
still the top comeback in football
history NFL history as far as I know as
far as I know it is yes do you bring it
up with your players I probably in two
years and maybe brought it up once you
know probably brought it up I don't
bring it up that often but
there's I think there's a time and a
place for for everything and I try not
to just be dogmatic and say I'm never
gonna talk about this or I'm always
going to talk about that I think you got
to be open and you got to play off your
strengths and my past playing career was
something I bring to the table so I'll
strategically pull back into that yeah
because you if you're down at halftime
or whatever it is or in the fourth
quarter like you can draw upon this and
they have to they have to trust you that
okay I've been in this situation before
whether you bring it up or not I mean
just that confidence level of saying we
can do this because you were down by
over 30 points in those games in college
and the NFL and ended up winning those
so I think that there would be a little
bit there would be a time in a place to
bring that up to your team maybe Phillip
Rivers doesn't need that but Jacoby
Brissette probably could have used
something like that well well you guys
you guys helped us out us former players
who are coaches you helped us out and we
appreciate this in that you know there's
still so much that shows I mean that
comeback game shows on air it's talked
about it's brought up in all the Sports
Talk stuff so you know and our players
are they're hearing all this stuff so it
actually gives you opportunity to bring
up some of those things where do you
keep your Super Bowl ring from the
Eagles it's in a law it's in a safe
deposit box have you brought it out to
show the players I have not I have not
you know we talked about you don't want
this interesting question Dan you know
and I have a coach Peterson was gracious
enough to get all the coaching staff a
replica replica Lombardi Trophy and one
of the things that I've talked to our
players about is man the ring is awesome
the the tro it's awesome to hold that
trophy you know to kiss the trophy take
pictures with the trophy but in my
experience in my experience what's even
better than the trophy what's better
than the ring what's better than the
money that you get from winning that is
looking looking your teammates in the
eye and saying we stink and did it we
are the best in the world we are world
champions
that's a shield that you wear the rest
of your life that that's worth more than
anything to me to look
your teammates you know we wanted to
climb the top of this mountain and it's
the hardest mountain to climb in sports
and we did it together I'm fired up
ready run through a wall right now coach
that wall right behind you that drywall
it's a plain wall we drive right through
it
how about you just take the ring and
just put it out on the table in the
locker room first week and then just
walk out just the drop off like drop the
mic I think that'd be Greg he's uh it
was hard for me to want to bring out the
one ring I had when I have Adam Vanna
Terry see he's Frank Reich the Colts
head coach joining us is is Adam still
playing he's rehabbing and then we're
gonna we're in a wait-and-see mode okay
no see see how the rehab goes see where
it's all at but yeah we're in that wait
are you still a pastor
yeah I'm still retained I still in
ordained and still III will officiate a
wedding here and there in fact I'm
officiating wedding this summer of one
of our coaches I'm one of our young
coaches who who is a we've become very
close so I still enjoying I probably do
officiate one wedding every two or three
years I really enjoy doing that it's a
lot of fun what if one of your players
asked you I would absolutely do it I
would absolutely do it what's the charge
on that though coach no charge no charge
actually I shouldn't say that
actually I hope you don't want mommy
saying this but when Andrew got married
I didn't officiate the wedding but I had
to because he got married out of the
country
Chris Ballard and I actually served as
witnesses and I had to sign a document
here back in the states that had to be
signed by an ordained minister and and I
said I signed that document so that's so
that's a real privilege do you think
Andrew would want to be a coach
assistant coach and not look we're
talking honor yeah that's a fair
question I mean obviously you'd have to
ask him I mean just the the time I've
spent with him I don't know I don't know
the answer that question
he is a you know he's a unique guy I
love him he's uh I've really got very
close with them still close to under
this day we still talk obviously even
though he
retire but he's going to be great at
whatever he does next you try to talk
him out of that just say no no that's it
no not even thought never even crossed
my mind I know that's that would be
foolish to try to do that that's a
decision you got it that's got to come
from here and you know any attempts to
do that would be vain conceit by me to
think that I could actually do that yeah
that would be foolish I think Phillip
Rivers you bring him in I know it's a
one-year deal but I see quotes see
reports that you know it's one and then
how does Phillip feel after one year is
that fair assessment of the future
quarterbacking position yeah it's
absolutely fair assessment and you know
we have all the respect in the world for
him and he's had an unbelievable career
and we know he's 38 years old again and
turned 39 during this season so it's
number one how does he feel but you know
I mean he knows this is number two is
how does he perform and of course we
think he's going to perform from lights
out which is why we're you know why we
sign him and why we're paying and the
money that we're paying him I see no I
know him very very well I know his body
movements I know his arm strength I know
his arm motion that unique arm motion
that he has and as I watched his film
from the last couple years I've seen no
diminishing skills physically so we're
very excited about having him as our
quarterback this year do you know how
many kids Phillip ends it's hard to keep
counting okay I think you got a couple
sent a couple more there's eleven eleven
in the family to all nine children and
everything you see in here about Phillip
right in that regard about family it's
all true I mean it's fun I you know in
San Diego when we're together I was at
his house with his family with his
children playing in the backyard playing
football in the backyard with his kids
it's a family first mentality there it's
fun to be around I had Mike Vrabel on
recently and I said did you guys do a
drive-by on Tom Brady and he said yeah
we looked at everybody here how close
did you get to you no interest in Tom
Brady yeah it was the same thing we
looked at everybody
that's our job I mean Chris Ballard I
thought it did a phenomenal job and he
and I you know especially at this at
every
but at the quarterback position and you
know we like I said from the beginning
we we love Jacoby percent so we looked
at every option we talked through every
option and we just thought we thought
Phillip Rivers was God for us it was a
unique connection that myself and Nick
seriani and Jason Michael all cotinine
we've all coached with Phillip before we
knew Phillip knows our system the
language is still pretty much the same
as a few things that have changed
Phillip was the right guy for us I love
your draft I Jonathan Taylor at a
Wisconsin but I love Michael Pittman
Michael Pittman just is a football
player and and I I don't know what which
one of those two do you have do you feel
like we'll be able to contribute more
right away you know that's a great
question I mean life's history and stats
would tell you it's a little bit harder
for receivers to have an impact early on
but I think and this is one of the
reasons we like Michael he's got a
physical and emotional maturity about
him that we think he can come in and
make in a more immediate impact than
most receivers do and so and obviously
we think Jonathan can come in and make a
big impact as well so we feel really
good about both of them yeah I like
Pittman a lot I mean Taylor has tailored
that size and has that speed and you
guys are a running attack maybe you
didn't want to be as much of a running
TAC attack as you were last year and
that's why you're bringing in Phillip
but it's nice to you know see Jonathan
Taylor just sitting there for you you
know how excited you get when you see
something like that where you just do
you giggle like a schoolgirl
well maybe not like a schoolgirl but let
me just tell you there's a lot of
there's I wake up with a lot of juice
and I think about our team and I and I
start visualizing what it's going to
look like this this fall assuming were
playing and on time and all that fun
stuff but I'm excited and I see in in
Pittman and Jonathan Taylor and then you
add guys like T Y Hilton and Marlin Mac
and Jack Doyle and all the other
playmate you know and I see were very
unselfish team I see us spreading the
ball around I see us being dual-threat
run and
my CS being a really good situational
team on third down and in the red zone
I see our defense really taking in
another step I'm really excited about
you know we get to force button or you
know adding to you know Justin Hughes
and then already in a young defense I
mean we are young young young on defense
and just on the rise so I see a good
football team in my mind right now what
do you know about the start of the
season
not much I mean you know it's changed a
couple of times so my mindset and our
mind said when I talked to the team is
hey we're assuming we're starting
training camp on time we're assuming
we're playing all our normal schedule
with fans in the stadium we all know
things could change or that so we'll be
ready for that just know players you
know that we as coaches have plans for
all of that we know how to adjust and
adapt we want I want the players to feel
confidence you know that hey no matter
what they get thrown at them we've
thought about every scenario we have
schedules for everything we've talked it
through Chris Ballard and I talked day
and night about this stuff we're in
coaching staff so we're ready
but our mindset is we're playing ball
start weak and I also think it's
beneficial Phillip knows the system he's
worked with you and Nick so he knows
that system and that that's where you
can hit the ground running I'll leave
you with this coach you can see the guys
that I have with me my dad's do you
think Quentin Nelson could beat up all
four my guys at once good-looking crew
but I would love to see them try to move
Quentin off the spot he just stand like
when he used to play king of the
mountain somebody stand on top of the
hill and your and your team guys right
here trying to knock him off the hill
that's a pretty entertaining thought I
had an NFL scout tell me prior to the
draft he said the best player in the
draft is not gonna be taken number one
and I said who's that he said Quentin
Nelson I said so a guard is not is the
best player in the draft he said he's
got the meanest streak he's a Hall of
Famer in waiting and he will start right
away
so when he went to the Colts and I
thought Andrew Luck has got somebody
there's going to protect him and Quentin
Nelson has lived up to those
expectations
he's a he's a throwback it feels like
Coach it really is and and your words
are exactly right and and he has lived
up to those in every way on and off the
field and his mentality is infectious
he's a leader he's tough minded yeah how
can that be that who would have ever
thought that we could be saying that
about a guard you know he's really he's
really one of these generational players
that you know we were very fortunate to
have I work on the backdrop there okay I
you look like you're being held hostage
there I appreciate it I was just doing
this so you would ask me back again
improvement the Nexus put like a
Maryland banner up there or something
code have your kids scribble on the
walls or some I don't know honest I'm
worried about you that's it Thank You
coach all right
that's a Frank Reich cold said coach